What's that? The
motion here is new.
[Music]
Technique:
Black
cloud.
Combination of weapons. I
attacked. If you can't defeat me on your first appearance, you'll have a chance. Hey,
Minaki and the cat keep repeating the same techniques.
[Music]
If that's the case, you'll be better. You can always survive. This is
how it is.  Don't think you can defeat me. Now that I'm here, I'm
thinking clearly. I'm
moving with all my might, fast. What should I do? My
feet are perfect. This is different from my previous techniques. I
have no choice but to aim for the ultimate.  I'm going to stand up to you with this god. I can even stand my
dragon.
[Music]
Heaven. I'm sure it's a life from heaven, but I don't know what it is. But
this technique is so fast.
[Music] I was
waiting to see if it would reach me,
but I said it.
[Music] That's it.  I
think you can beat me